et nous allons accueillir cette
ravissante vanessa regarde comme elle
est jolie fait une grosse bise à
philippe là et vous applaudissez très
fort regarde on aurait dit que j'avais
préparé le micro pour toi qu'elle reste
qu à vanessa s'étend et toi tu es
française oui si tu habites villiers sur
marne en tue pas venus de très loin qui
est venu en famille tu venu tout seul
enfin alors qu'est ce qu'il ya dans ta
famille papa et mon pari ma maman mon
papa et mon parrain où il est on va pas
c'est le moustachu un oui ça pique ses
moustaches vous et pippa on quitte pas
assez démoussage hippiques paris
les papas ont toujours des moustaches
qui piquent pas comment il s'appelle
thomas more boring on joue encore et ils
travaillent tous les deux mr oui au fun
parce que vous êtes tu as des frères et
des soeurs une petite fille unique
oui ça te plairait d'avoir des frères et
des soeurs ont combien tu en voudrait ma
chérie une faune une seule voie là est
ce qu'il vous reste à faire un jeu vous
aurez le bon de commande à remplir tout
à l'heure didon j'ai l'impression comme
ça que tu fais un peu de danse parce que
tu as l'air bien tu fais un peu de danse
non oui de la danse classique pour m
avoir commencé montre moins prêt moi un
petit peu de temps c'est mauvais
recommencer de la danse rythmique à
monza
c'est pas comme ça là dans ce tube tu
fais tu fais de la danse rythmique et tu
veux pas me montrer
alors tu veux chanter quand même oui
qu'est-ce que tu vas chanter i me joly
les voilà emilie jolie c'était celle que
j'attendais parce que je la chante tout
le temps facile
[Musique]
je m'appelle emilie jolie je m'appelle
emilie jolie
j'ai joué des parties
vous tout goût du sel sur mauvais et je
voudrais vie
les goûts
ma
[Musique]
oh
tu t'appelles et
joli
j'ai envie
tu voudrais partie
tout vous dire si
et tu voudrais dire avec nous
oui c'est ça mon mari à la
pittman
je rappelle émilie jolie
tu rêves de voler
parti rejoindre les
et
la lune simon hughes et ils devraient
m
[Musique]
oui
coupet
allez
temarii
miyata machin
je partais pour le virement
la page est tournée
la vie ne fait de même ainsi
yat un chat
ce n'est pas rien
[Musique]
denis
qui
de tami
richard doucet bien voir c'est ce que je
disais et autour des champions et
utiliser cette petite fille chante très
très très juste tu fais de la musique
passé pour ça c'est une petite pianistes
ont applaudi très fort et on lui donne
une note
attention philippe que 13 attentif parce
qu'il faut pas qu'ils aient deux soeurs
cédric tu choisis ce que tu veux voilà
dix très bien cédric 10 10 9 10 et 8
vous reposer vos plaquettes et notre
avant derniers candidats
un ravissant petit garçon qui s'appelle
david